hundreds of homes and businesses
demolished to make way for the new hs2
station at Houston but now construction
has essentially ground to a halt this
spring the government decided to pause
the work here and on the high-speed line
north of Birmingham to crew for two
years local people are fed up well for
the last three or four years it's been
horrendous the noise
and the vibrations you'll be vibrating
inside in bed everything flattened to
the ground and then there are still
happy they're taking two years off for
what
the government says the delays are to
balance the books but a recent hs2
briefing exclusively leaked to Sky News
predicts an extra
366 million pound cost as a result and
potentially more as this is just a
projected impact of the delayed section
of track the analysis also suggests the
two-year pause will actually lead to a
three and a half year delay because of
the additional work needed to get the
project back up and running labor say
it's a bombshell briefing the chaotic
indecision and mismanagement of 13 years
of hs2 has held back 30 billion pounds
of economic growth it's left an
abandoned building site here in Houston
and it's holding back economies in the
north as well demonstrated today that
it's cost taxpayers another 400 million
pounds on the many many wasted millions
that the Tories have already spent over
the years the cost of hs2 was shot up
from 38 to more than 71 billion pounds
the plan is meant to be a key part of
the leveling up agenda
the new high-speed trains will travel at
up to 225 miles an hour meaning my
current Journey from London to
Manchester would take just over one hour
compared to more than two on existing
services like this one but the recent
delays mean high-speed trains won't get
to Manchester until at least 2040 for
businesses like bromwood which runs
co-working spaces is hugely frustrating
what business thrives on is having real
certainty and knowing when things are
coming just makes all the difference and
so having this sort of stop start are we
going to have investment in
infrastructure are we not it's just
really destabilizing you know we have
got it feels second class infrastructure
in the north the department for
transport told us that hs2 will bring
transformational benefits but has to be
funded sustainably they say over the
next two years some stages will be
re-phased to ensure they're delivered in
the most cost effective way but for now
the final destination is even further
away Amanda raycast Sky News